This is the first challenge problem, and this is a problem that I don't necessarily expect you to be
able to get right with the knowledge you have, but I think it's a pretty interesting problem.
So if you wanted to challenge yourself, go ahead and take a shot. It's completely optional.
Now, I want you to go to a sink or a bathroom or somewhere you have access to a water faucet.
Turn that faucet on. Take a look at the water as it falls down.
You'll notice that it doesn't look like this as you might expect.
In reality, the water tapers off. It gets thinner and thinner as it falls.
So after it has fallen in the distance y, the initial radius R has reduced to r.
The question here is, can you find a mathematical equation that represents
the radius of this column of water as a function of y.
There's a couple of key insights to make here.
And first is that the water passing through an imaginary hoop does so at a constant rate
and that is totally confusing if I don't explain it more.
What I mean is if I drew an imaginary ring here and an imaginary ring here
and let the water pass through both of them.
If 1 L of water is passing through this ring every minute,
then 1 L must be passing through this ring too.
None of the water is splashing off to the side. It's not building up in the middle.
So it must be the case that the water's flow rate is constant.
You can also show that this flow rate well is equal to the velocity of the water through a given ring
times the area, the cross-sectional area of the water at that point--so that would be πr².
Third, we have to assume that the water when it leaves the faucet already has some velocity.
It's moving downwards at V₀.
So what I want you to do is to write an equation that the radius of this water is a function of how far
it's fallen, y, in terms of y is initial velocity and g the acceleration on earth, which is 10 m/s².
This question won't be graded because it's a challenge question.
But when you get your answer, you should share it with your classmates in the forums
and talk about it, and I think this is really an interesting problem.